et au lendemain de l'incendié qui s'est
déclaré au siège du parti ennahdha en
plein coeur de tunis une enquête a été
ouverte pour déterminer les causes
exactes du drame l'immolation d'un
militant en serait à l'origine bilan son
décès et 18 blessés parmi lesquels des
personnalités politiques les précisions
dans notre correspondant en tunisie bfm
chebbi
un morts 18 blessés tel est le bilan de
l'incendié survenu hier après midi au
siège du mouvement ennahdha dans le
quartier de montplaisir en plein coeur
de tunis selon les premières
informations du ministère de l'intérieur
un corps calciné a été découvert par les
pompiers est identifié comme étant celui
d'un ancien agent d'accueil au siège du
parti l'homme de 41 ans présenté par le
tribunal de première instance de tunis
comme un ancien prisonnier politique se
serait immolé par le feu au rez de
chaussée du bâtiment certaines personnes
présentes sur les lieux n'ont pas hésité
à se défenestrer pour éviter lé plaçant
parmi elles le vice-président du parti
ali larayedh transporté en urgence à
l'hôpital un important cordon de
sécurité a été mis en place par les
forces de l'ordre et à ce jour p de
périmètre est toujours quadrillé et hors
d'accès lors d'une région lors d'une
réunion de conseil de sécurité nationale
tenue ce matin le chef de l'état qui
haïssent ayed a déclaré qu'une enquête
est en cours pour déterminer les causes
exactes de cet incendie et savoir si
c'est un acte criminel ou le résultat
d'une auto immolation